hello everyone and welcome to a
wonderful game from the prague chess
festival this is round four and so many
of you guys have requested this one uh
for very good reasons it features a very
very rare end game especially uh one
that would arise in a classical game
between players of um of such strength
and uh
it's just one of those uh
remarkable end games so you guys will
enjoy it if you don't know what happened
in this one and if you're wondering why
i'm not in my usual setup i'm currently
traveling but i will be back home before
the candidates so that's why i'm here in
this sort of a weird room now getting
back to the game now it's parham xudulu
of course you all know him he's the i
believe now now the number one uh
iranian player and pentala harikrishna
of course hari is extremely well known
very very strong indian grand master so
no need for any further introduction
now let's get straight to it because the
game and not just the end game because
the end game is what this is all about
and why you guys requested it but the
game in itself is very enjoyable as well
so maxwell opens with the d4 we have d5
and c4 the queen's gambit is on the
board we have c6 now uh transposing into
the slop defense knight f3 knight to f6
and now pawn to e3 uh we have bishop to
f5 and now knight to c3 uh e6 and now
knight to h4 the bishop is now out of
the cage all of the pawns are on light
squares you have a dark square bishop
that you can use to go in between those
pawns and now we harass the light square
bishop so bishop to e4 we harass it
further bishop back to g6 and the queen
to b3 again this is all very well known
and both of them of course know this
queen to b6 and now knight captures and
g6 grabbing the bishop pair h captures
and g6 now black gets the semi-open h
file bishop to d2 and do not knight beat
the d7 uh neither player wants to
capture the queen of course everyone
wants to get a semi-open a file for the
rook so here we have queen side castles
and now it is actually best to trade
queens here and of course both of them
know this so queen captures on b3 a
captures and bishop to b4 and now
we have king the c2 also bishop to d3 uh
is is a move that can be played here and
it was played here but king the c2 is a
rare one but again not a new one so here
queen side castles by black as well
bishop to d3 and pawn to a6 and here we
have bishop back to e1 and it is now uh
only as of move 15 that we have a
completely new game now you still have
the bishop
going
after the this bishop you you have the
rook nicely uh placed on the d-file and
you can shift the bishop over to g3 if
needed to cut off the king from going
further queen side which also might be
useful if you imagine let's say you have
a bishop on g
on g3 slicing over here this knight
moves knight to b6 uh will be checkmate
so even such ideas are maybe possible in
some lines uh so here bishop back to d6
we of course want to counter the bishop
if the bishop comes to g3 and now pawn
to h4
knight to e8 we have pawn to e4 striking
in the center knight to c7 uh and now we
have bishop to f2 we have bishop to e7
and now pawn to g4 just grabbing more
space on the queen side pawn to a5 and
now bishop to g3 putting bishop on this
beautiful diagonal
and here uh knight to b8 and if you now
consider this position it's a very
complicated one but also it is uh dead
equal
if you allow the engine to crunch the
numbers i did it uh you know i i
left the engine to crunch the numbers i
went for a walk outside on the beach i
uh returned after some maybe 20 minutes
and at the depth 45 to 50 the engine
says the position is
0.00 so it's in equal position so bishop
back to e2 now comes bishop to d6
offering a trade of dark square bishops
and maxulou declines bishop back to not
f2 sorry uh e5 now uh
winning more space in the center
attacking the bishop bishop to b4 and
now pawn to c5 and now it seems like
you've
stranded this bishop on b4 but not
really black will now just challenge the
overextended c5 pawn c captures on b6
and now uh knight to a8 now we're going
to win this pawn back so it's not really
upon sacrifice knights the a2 going
after the bishop and the bishop back to
e7 we have bishop back to e1 going after
the a5 pawn and king to b7 we have
bishop captures on a5 and now pawn to c5
trading the other c pawn as well
and then only then will we go after the
b6 pawn so here are d captures in c5
bishop captures and pawn to b4 uh we
have a triple b pawn so it makes sense
to
give up one of them uh and we don't
really have a ch
say in the matter so bishop captures on
b6 pawn to f for now opening up this
diagonal which will be incredibly useful
later on rook to c8 check and now you
could go king to b3 grab more space with
the king but here knight to c3 first
only then will maxwell will go king to
b3
knight to c6 going after the bishop and
now bishop captures on b6 we have knight
characters on b6 and king to b3 so you
can see that uh again uh it's a very
very interesting position it's no longer
dead equal here white is actually better
the problem is the white king is on b3
and uh it's uh
the king is very very close to the two
knights and also imagine this rook
coming to the a file and this rook
coming to the c file the king being
stranded on the b file uh will be very
scary and that's kind of exactly what
happens in the game so rook to a8 we
have pawn to b5 and now knight the a5
with check but maxwell
is uh is a brave one he goes king to b4
we have knight eight to c4 and now even
pawn to b3 chasing away this knight
uh if you if you could somehow check the
king once again and force it uh for
force the king to c5 and that would be
incredible but for the moment you don't
have a way to do that so knight to the
e3 going after this c to check uh if you
allow this then it's going to be very
unpleasant so here rook to c1 uh rook
the d2 was much stronger here but that
will only be
uh
it's only possible to realize this later
on uh when uh when you will see what
hari krishna finds it's a it's a very
cool tactical shot uh but rook the c2
was the way to go here after rook to c1
which kind of covers the c2 square as
well it's just not as powerful because
now rook h the c8 like we mentioned the
king completely stranded now on the b
file we have bishop to f3 aligning the
bishop with the king very nicely on this
diagonal but now comes the move that
would not be possible if the rook was on
d2 because the other rook would be
guarding the a1 square as well so here
rook to a1 that's the that's the punch
line here now of course the rook cannot
be captured either you get knight to c2
checking a5 and then the other rook just
delivers checkmate so that's out of the
question so here just h5 and this is the
start of a beautiful beautiful weight uh
uh
break breakthrough with the white king
this is just incredible uh g characters
on h5 we have g captures on h5 king to
b8 now uh getting the king away from
this diagonal and it now seems like uh
you can just grab the rook because black
will no longer have rook to a8 checkmate
like in the line that we've discussed
but you would be very wrong to do this
because if you capture the rook now
again knights the sea to check king the
a5 and just king b7 there's no defense
against rook to a8 so even though you
don't have checkmate right away you can
just prepare it white has no moves here
so instead after king to b5 we have f5
and this is just just remarkable how
matsulu
is is finding a way out for his king
this is uh incredible e captures an f5
now pawn to h6 and what is this g
captures an h6 now comes rook captures
on a1 and
is the position just not the exact same
position that we just saw isn't white
getting checkmated not really because
after knight the c to check king to a5
king to b7 it seems now okay you are
getting checkmated with rook to a8 uh
luckily bishop captures on d5 with check
that's in the position and now you
cannot you can't just move the king for
example king to c7 because we play rook
eight to c1 and now you don't have
checkmate the bishop covers the eighth
square that's the problem so the bishop
has to be captured knight captures on
the e5 it is the only good move for
black here and now comes rook captures
an h6 that's what all the pawn pushing
on the king side was about uh preventing
checkmate because now you have a rook to
a6 and there's really no reason for
black to do this if rook to a6 check
okay you will grab the rook on a1
because that was hanging all along
knight captures on d5 white is just
better white is up a pawn also black has
a double def pawn so
if anything
it's either or white will win this so
that's not the way to do it so instead
rook captures and see c3 and now rook to
a4 uh we need uh
uh to get to move the rook away from
here and also we kind of want to keep it
on the a file uh we don't want to allow
the black rook to deliver
some sort of a checkmate here because
all of these squares are covered around
the the white king one check with the
rook and the a file and the checkmate so
rook to a4 and now knight seat to e3
we have pawn to e6 now breaking through
with uh
with uh with with the rook f captures
rook captures uh and now we have pawn to
f4 uh starting to
advance the past pawn and here the
position is still equalish but you have
to play it very passively you have to
play something like rook eight put the
rook behind the pass pawn to cover the
edf file uh and hopefully you will
survive however here uh maxullu says uh
all right this is uh this is a dead draw
we can just give up the rooks and the
two knights i mean against the king
that's a draw even with the the the
extra two pawns uh it's it's not a
position that can be won so rook
captures on f4 he gives up the rook we
have knight captures on f4 and now rook
the b6 with check uh either getting a
perpetual with rook a6 rogue b6 rook a6
rook b6 or forcing the king to the c
file which will happen in the game and
now rook to c6 check he trades the other
rook as well or rather sacrifice the
sacrifices the one rook or not even a
sacrifice he gave it up for a pawn that
cannot be considered a sacrifice that's
just okay maybe it could but it's um
it's it's great if it works uh so rook
captures on c6 b captures on c6 and now
knight eat the d5 you don't want to
gobble up the pawns if you gobble up the
pawns then it's a draw everyone knows
that king against the king with two
knights that's a draw
except if you go for help mate or if uh
you know
uh it's a it's a setup position that
that allows you but it's still
impossible to checkmate without at least
white having one pawn so here pawn to b4
uh white just wants to push the pawns
all the way and force the black king to
capture them or the black knights
knights the b6 now we're gonna stop the
pawns and we will try and get some sort
of a favorable position where we can uh
checkmate the white king by releasing
the pawns at the precise right you know
exactly precise moment so king b5 we
have knight to e6 uh and now uh king
back to a6 we have king captures and c6
white only needs one pawn so we can
checkmate him uh b5 check we have king
the c5 and king the b7 we have knight to
d8 with check king to c7 and now knight
to f7 cutting over the white king
completely here the two knights create a
wall so king back to b7 and now knight
to e5 we have king back to c7 knight e
to d7 now
uh we have king to d8 the black king
just wants to go anywhere except you
know b in the corner king to d6 and now
king to e8 we have knight to e5 now
taking the f7 square from the king king
to f8 and now king to e6 with king to g7
now comes king to f5 and here
white played king to h6 but this is a
problem king interestingly king to h7 is
a draw the only move that ensures the
draw for white however king to h6 is not
a draw but you have to play the absolute
uh precise move uh otherwise you're not
going to be able to to use your tempe
properly to check made the white king so
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find this incredible idea while i
give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on realizing that
this is actually a forced checkmate in
22 moves and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is king to g4
that's the only move that wins and that
the only move that
will give us the the opposition uh now
if king h7 we go king to h5 if king g7
we go king to g5 and we keep the
opposition so here king the h7 was
played now king to h5 king g7 king to g5
now king h7 and now we have knight to f7
with this move maksulu is back in the
game because knight to f7 is one of the
few moves that doesn't actually win the
game uh many other moves like knight to
the g four knight e to d7 king to h5
those are still all winning but after
knight to f7 uh the white king can now
escape because the white king can now
grab the opposition uh with king the g8
or rather
invited the black king into opposition
however here in the game king to g7 was
played now the opposition doesn't work
in white's favor uh now it's again
completely winning in 11 moves
knight to d6 now
we have king to h7 knight to f5 we've
came to g8 and now king to f6 so what we
want to do is box the white king in
completely and now we cover this square
we covered this square with the knight
we covered this square we still need to
cover this square to keep the white king
boxed in so uh the the white king needs
to only have these squares and then we
can release the pawn and allow uh white
those four magical moves in order to
checkmate him so here king the h7 uh
king to f7 also doesn't help a king to
f8 doesn't help just knight here and
again these squares are taken away from
you you have to go back so here king the
h7 was played now comes king to f7 the
king now completely boxed in look at the
king only has these two squares to move
uh knight controls h6 of course and the
king controls g6 g7 and g8 uh here we
have king to h8 and now those four
magical moves now we finally release uh
you know the the pawn uh knight the d7
and he was in this position on move 74
uh that uh
that uh parham axulu resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
so now it's a fourth checkmate
with the knight to d7 moving for and
there is nothing you can do about it
this you can just make moves with the
king but it doesn't matter for example
if king to h7 we just play knight to f6
with check the king has to go to h8 we
play knight to e7 and the king now has
no more moves you have to make a pawn
move that's why it was important to
release the pawn at the just the right
time so just the right time means that
you white will not be able to grab a
queen and start checking you but also
not so much that uh white just uh you
know uh
loses the pawn or something and then
it's uh it's a draw by by stalemating
the white king so here pawn to b6 knight
to g6 will be checkmate or
uh if instead of going king to h7 you
just push the pawn pawn to b6 uh now we
just again start our uh uh you know
dance of the knights okay we have knight
to f6 pawn to b7 and now it's pretty
much the same knight to e7 we even allow
white to bring a queen into the game or
any other piece doesn't really matter
because it doesn't come with check
and now knight to g6 will be checkmate
so really really a remarkable game that
could have gone uh either way it was uh
really really crazy stuff happening all
the way maxwell really playing it brave
there bringing his king all the way i
mean this was just incredible and uh
it's interesting that white is white is
much better here and maxulo of course
knew this uh but just allowing this
position where you know you have the
rook on the c file the rook on the a
file the knights so close to the white
king uh it was obviously obviously too
much pressure and here where you had to
continue playing passively uh you know
with the idea of rook to e8 rook to f8
just controlling the f-pawn uh he
thought that he would be able to get a
draw here and he was right actually rook
captures and f4 still uh will
should be a draw
but with perfect play though it all came
down to that one move where the king
here should have gone to h7 instead of
on h6 so here with king to h7 still a
draw but with king to h6 the position is
winning so that's why even though you
know that you probably will not win uh
two nights against the king and pawn uh
it's possible to win it even against an
incredibly strong grandmaster like
parham maxwell
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it it was really really really a
wild one i really enjoyed watching it um
especially since so many of you guys
suggested that i knew that something
crazy has happened uh but you know
always something crazy happens in prague
it's just the way prague is uh i would
like to thank adrian marcin nagorski
david kaiser tyler singer clark benjamin
bogweld and martin georg paparik for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions such as this one
and please do suggest as much as
possible i'm
basically on a vacation now so maybe i
do a video maybe i don't all depends on
how how the day goes uh but it's much
much easier if you guys suggest such
lovely games for me to cover
so yeah once again thank you all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day